you cousin about the census well I think
that and I'm not overly involved in that
that's really a legal matter but I think
when you have a census and you're not
allowed to talk about whether or not
somebody's a citizen or not that doesn't
sound so good to me can you imagine you
send out a census and you're not allowed
to say whether or not a person is an
American citizen in Poland they say
they're either Polish or they're not
right so I don't want to get you into
this battle but it's it's it's
ridiculous I think it's I think it's
totally ridiculous that we would have a
census without asking but the Supreme
Court is going to be ruling on it soon I
think when a census goes out you should
find out whether or not and you have the
right to ask whether or not somebody is
a citizen of the United States okay yes
ma'am what we're talking about it that's
one of the reasons that we're here a lot
of money's going to be spent on a
facility a military facility a great one
there a very good location in Poland and
actually it'll be spread over a little
area but basically one primary facility
we'll see how it works out we're talking
about it right I hope we're with
everybody and I hope not I think that
Russia will treat Poland with respect
just like the rest of the world is
treating Poland has really built up a
great country you know they get they get
hurt unfortunately too often right too
often they end there in the middle of
everything and when bad things happen it
seems that Poland is always the first
one that's in there and it's it's
unfortunate no I hope that Russia and
Poland and Germany and everybody's going
to get along that's what I want I want
everybody to get along
reaction to the demonstrations in Hong
Kong it is China over playing its hand
well their massive demonstrations I look
today and that really is a million
people a lot of times people talk about
they had 2,000 people but it was really
1,000 or was 200 I see it all the time I
see it all the time but when you look at
this demonstration they said it was a
million people that was a million people
that was as big a demonstration as I've
ever seen so I hope it all works out for
China and for Hong Kong I don't know
what they're sending I mean that's a
demonstration that they're having I
understand the reason for the
demonstration but I'm sure they'll be
able to work it out I hope they're going
to be able to work it out with China
well we're going to be discussing a lot
of those elements today no because we
have great internal polling they will
fake polls that will let release by
somebody that is it's ridiculous no we
are winning in every single state that
we fold we're winning in Texas very big
we're winning in Ohio very big while
winning in Florida very big they were
fake polls that were either put out by
the corrupt media as much of the media
in this country unfortunately it's
corrupt I have to tell you that mr.
president and some of it is excellent
but some is very bad those are fake
numbers but you know when you're going
to see that you're going to see that on
Election Day
when Election Day you can see it was the
same thing I had the same thing for I
had the same thing for a long period of
time in 2016 I was getting these
terrible poll numbers and I didn't see
it because I'd have tremendous crowds
and my opponent would have almost nobody
and I said I think we're gonna win the
state of Michigan we did I think we're
going to win the state of Wisconsin
Pennsylvania Ohio and we won them all
and now I have the same stuff they're
giving our phony calls know these are
polls that we have that nobody saw we do
very little polling because I'm
a huge believer in polling I think you
go out there and you fight and you don't
really need polls you have to you need
ideas more than polls but we have some
internal polling very little and it's
unbelievably strong the strongest I've
ever been is exactly today no they're
not advisers that's fake news you don't
understand what I'm saying those
advisers don't exist they don't exist
it's made up by the newspapers it's fake
news well I think what the Democrats are
trying to do because they know they're
going to lose the election so they're
gonna give this a shot they're gonna
just every day they're gonna be going
more and more after after I don't know
if you have this mr. president but we
have people that are totally out of
control it's the only way they think
they can win the election so we'll see
what happens but at some point the
mahler report spoke they were very
disappointed it said no collusion and no
obstruction and no nothing and in fact
it said we actually rebuffed your
friends from Russia that we actually
pushed them back we rebuffed them so the
Democrats were very unhappy with the
malla report so now they're trying to do
a do-over or a redo and we're not doing
that we gave them everything we were the
most transparent presidency in history
we gave them everything and you and I
we've all had this conversation many
times before there's never been anybody
so transparent gave them 1.5 million
documents we gave them hundreds of
people I gave them lawyers which I
didn't have to give I didn't have to
give anybody we gave them everybody and
people that didn't like Donald Trump 18
Trump haters 18 Democrats and they were
Trump haters and they were supporters in
some cases of Hillary Clinton they made
the decision and Bob Mahler no fan of
Donald Trump I'm no fan of his and Bob
Mahler came out with a report that said
no collusion and by the way and led to
no obstruction so now the Democrats want
to try and win it elect
so they just keep it going and I think
the American public's not going to stand
for it I'll tell you what the Democrats
should be doing they should be working
on the border they should work be
working on drug pricing and they should
be working on infrastructure where we
could get that done very quickly but
they don't have any time to do anything
and I think it's going to be a
tremendous day for us it's a year and a
half now until the election I think it's
going to be a tremendous day for us we
expect to have a meeting with President
Xi we're doing very well with respect to
China we're taking in billions and
billions of dollars which we never took
in before the tariffs are been you know
very strong we have 25 percent of 250
billion dollars and tremendous money is
flowing into our treasury China is
subsidizing those companies so our
people are not paying for it if you look
our people are not paying for it China
is subsidizing those companies so that
people continue to work now the problem
for China is that a lot of companies are
leaving China because they don't want to
pay the tariffs but we're doing very
well and I think I have a feeling that
we're going to make a deal with China
because I really don't believe that
China wants to continue the problem that
they really caused themselves because we
had a deal done almost I would say all
of the tough points were negotiated they
were negotiated and they were agreed to
and everything was finished and then
China told us they can't agree to things
that they already agreed on all right
and that's okay so I said that's okay
we're gonna put tariffs on 25 percent on
two hundred and fifty billion dollars
now we have another three hundred and
twenty five billion dollars left and if
we don't make a deal we're gonna put a
tariff on that too and the United States
is making more money than they've ever
made ever ever before from China I'd
like to make a deal but we'll see what
happens but I can tell you as much as
I'd like to China wishes they had that
deal to do over again because what they
did was wrong you can't renegotiated a
deal we had a deal that was done and
they wanted to renegotiate you can't do
that
I think I will we haven't picked a date
but we will I just had an incredible
time that speech was special from the
standpoint of the people of Poland and I
know it was considered a very important
speech you people even gave me very high
marks in that speech I could say it but
I don't want to say it but some people
said it was the best speech ever made by
a president in Europe but I did not say
that I'm just quoting other people but
it was a great it was a great day the
two folks you treated us so great I'll
never forget it we won't forget our trip
to Poland very very tremendous special
people I'm not concerned I know the
president very well I know the people
and the leadership of Poland very well
I'm not concerned at all by the way
Poland is doing so well and they know if
they do backslide they won't be doing
well like they're doing right now
they've probably never done better
economically they're like us the US has
never done better economically that
we're doing right now they don't want to
backslide they won't backslide and
besides that they owe us a lot of money
because they're buying a lot of things
right so that's important so they have
to do well we have to make sure they do
well we're very very happy we're falling
you may want to say something about this
that's not one chief of you sorry
someone cheated you there is no problems
with democracy in Poland really
everything is excellent that's what I
hear
this would be a certainly a statement
that the US would be making I don't talk
about permanence or non permanence but
this would be a statement that the u.s.
is making Steve go ahead well they're
talking about 2,000 troops but we'd be
taking them out of Germany or would be
moving them from another location it
would be no additional troops to Europe
we'd be moving them from another
location as you know we have 52,000
troops in Germany and Germany is not
living up to what they're supposed to be
doing with respect to NATO and Poland is
I have to congratulate you thank you
very much but Poland is paying the max
the max will be raised I raised over a
hundred billion dollars last year from
countries that were not paying and it
wasn't fair to the United States so we
put and they put up over a hundred
billion dollars more but as you know
Germany's at 1% they should be a 2% and
they're not getting there fast
we have 52,000 troops in Germany we've
had them there for a long long time so
we'd be probably moving a certain number
of troops to Poland if we agree to do it
Poland's going to build a phenomenal
facility in a very good location we
haven't totally made up a decision no we
haven't we haven't finalized anything
but the facility itself would be
world-class well that's up to them I
have nothing to do with naming it for
trouble that's all I need for Trump you
people would have a field day with that
right that's up to them thank you